you've also
kind of mentioned moderation which is
really interesting
so with this anonymity and this
community
i don't know if you've heard of the
internet but there's trolls on the
internet
so i've heard and uh even if they go to
yale and dartmouth uh there's still
people that
probably enjoy uh the
sort of being the the guerrilla warfare
contra revolutionary and just like
creating chaos
in a place of uh love so how do you
prevent
chaos from and hatred uh breaking out in
librex
so the way i think about it is we have
these
principles um they're pretty simple and
they're pretty easy to enforce and then
beyond the principles we have a set of
moderators
moderate from every single ivy league
school scheme of diverse moderators to
enforce these principles but not only
enforce the principles
but kind of clue us in to what's
happening in their community
and how the real life context of their
community translates to the
librex context of their community and
beyond that we have conversation with
them
about the standards of the community and
we're constantly
talking about what needs to be further
elucidated and what needs to be
tweaked and we're in constant
communication with the community
now if you want me to get into the
principles that underlie librex's
moderation policy
yeah please maybe you can explain that
there's moderators what does that mean
how are they chosen and what are the
principles under which they operate
sure so how are the moderators chosen
the moderators are all volunteers
they're
librexers who reach out to me and
respond to the opportunity to become
moderator
and the way they're chosen is basically
we want to make sure that they're in
tune with
their community we want to make sure
they come from diverse backgrounds and
we want to make sure that they're
they sort of understand what the
community is about and then we
ask them some questions about how they
would deal with certain scenarios
ones that we've had in the past and we
feel strongly about
and then also ones that are a little
more murky where we want to see that
they're sort of thinking about these
things in a critical way
yeah um and from there we
choose a set and they have the power to
take down posts of course everything at
the end of the day
pens my review but they can take them
down and we can reinstate them if it's
if it's a problem but they can take down
posts and they can
advocate for you know different
moderation standards and different
moderation policies
so for now you're the lioness torvald of
this community and
uh it's a meaning like you're able to
like people are actually able to like
email you
or like text me text you contact you
and get a response like you respond to
basically everybody
and then you're you're like really you
know
you're you're living that live on
people's floor life
currently that's not necessarily this is
the early days folks
i knew right he was a billionaire and he
was cool
and then he was in a mansion uh making
meats
on his barbecue no okay
but you know how does it scale um like
what
i i suppose how does this scale is the
question i mean
with linus uh i don't know if you're
familiar with the linux
open source community but he still
stayed at the top for a while it was
really important like leadership there
was really important to drive
that large scale really productive open
source community
what do you see your your role as
libraries grows
and um in general what are the
mechanisms of scaling here for
moderation
though i see it open discourse is
fundamental to
the purpose of the app right so as the
i guess you could say founder ceo what
have you
part of my purpose has to be to enforce
the
vision right and part of the vision is
open discourse and that does come down
in part to reasonable moderation and
community-guided
reasonable moderation so i imagine that
will always be something that i'm
intimately involved with to some degree
now
the degree to which the way in which
that
manifests i imagine will have to change
right um
and hopefully i'll be able to just like
you can hire a cto
hopefully i'll be able to be in
integrated and hiring people who are
who understand the the way that we
are sort of operating in the and the
reasonable standards
of moderation and there can be a sort of
hierarchical structure
but i think when you have a product
whose
key purpose is to allow people to have
these difficult conversations on campus
that need to be had
yeah i can never record to that yeah i
can never
fully i don't think i can fully ever
abdicate that responsibility i think if
that would be like
i mean that would be like bezos
abdicating e-commerce
right right like that is that's part of
the job
yeah of course you can run companies in
different ways i think that
because he might have abdicated quite a
bit of the details there hard for me to
say
because the amazon does so many things i
think the probably the better examples
like elon with rock is he's still
at the core of the engineering he's at
the core of the engineering there's
some fundamental questions he probably
does way too much of the engineering
like he's like the lowest level detail
but you're saying like the core
things that are that make the app work
is
is the moderation of difficult
conversations and by the way
i'm 21 years old let's remind us
everyone of that
um if this thing
does scale and if this thing continues
to be a positive force in
a lot of people's lives who knows what
what will happen in the next what i'll
learn um i'm still growing
definitely as a leader still growing as
a thinker still growing as a person
i don't i can't pretend that i know how
to run
a business that is worth you know up
teen billion dollars whatever
yeah i can't pretend i know how to run a
business that's you know going to have
millions and millions of users
i expect that there are going to be a
lot of amazing people who will teach me
and that a lot of people who have
already kind of stepped into my life
and helped me out and taught me things
and i imagine that i'll learn so much
more i just know that
moderation is always going to be
important to me because i don't think
librex's librex unless we have open
discourse and moderation
reasonable open light touch moderation
is at the heart of creating that right
you